cuz we're gonna be
[Music]
possibly
[Applause]
[Music]
and you this was last Monday morning in
her life
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
nominee
Manzo
for you and me Ashton and I'll go
[Applause]
[Music]
be back in a nap
when to the Knicks game that was most of
my day 7 KJ honoring an amazing man it
was great when I caught up with Kelly
McCarthy who's a senior digital
marketing executive at Nike catching up
with Kelly for drinks my favorite fun
fact a lot of you don't know
besides AJ's biggest fan had to obey the
media's growth in the early days editor
so much is that Nike were tricking line
let's go I was a lot of fun
and strategizing the future and now I'm
going to sit down and this is going to
be the meat of the episode of to me a
meeting with which the kid a young man
who's been able to really hack culture
and especially in the hip-hop world and
fascinating guy and getting some uh some
soft starters for some opportunities
keep the [ __ ] a little bit Jam as you
guys can tell I've been really digging
deep in his culture right now narrowing
in on on hip hop quite a bit but I've
been also spending some time with uh
obviously athletes with the leaner
sports thing
most of it's been behind closed doors
and and then Instagram influencers right
just studying in the norms about a time
understanding the people that have
250,000 followers or more that are
following me have a bunch of them on DM
over the weekend condemning trying to
come up with collaboration different
ways to provide each other value for me
I continue to crave exposure looking for
as many people to know what I'm up to
because I've been noticing the
conversions very high once people get
aware of my stuff 20 percent hate me
because they think I'm too egotistical
too much bravado too loud too East Coast
80% are obsessed with it and then of
that 80% 50% so 40% are able to hold on
and actually put it to good use and then
temper some that 4% of my exposure they
really execute and their lives really
change and that is intoxicating I am
very much lately on this mission of
realizing I'm going to get mine now if I
can really help tens it's not
thousands of people getting theirs what
does it look like in a decade what's in
ten years I'm a partially or specially
responsible for hundreds of thousands of
people who have ten fifty hundred x
their lives their happiness the fortunes
makes me feel like there'll be a lot of
vis dev opportunities in 2027 and so uh
it's an incredible feeling and reminds
me of doing the right thing is always
the right thing and so just got off the
phone with one of the five biggest
golfers in the world that was fun
especially because me and Tyler and AJ a
lot of characters around me a big
golfing fans just [ __ ] along you know
here we are you know 8:22 meeting hasn't
even started yet MLK Day is a day where
a lot of people have been calling it a
non day working life and they have they
they packed it in a long time ago and
I'm proud I'm very proud that I'll be
here grinding in till 11 p.m. doing my
thing I think it separates me from a lot
of people a lot of people try to figure
out why this is happening ensure
charisma and smarts and natural talent
is a factor but don't ever get it
twisted about [ __ ] working you and
that is a major part of the equation and
you can do that to your competitor it is
the most controllable aspect in this
warfare of business and and for me I
can't make myself much more talented I
can't control a lot of the serendipity I
can control the hours I put in and I
feel intoxicated
[Music]
what I'm a man for the cinema man they
should coming up some miscarriage I call
and call call real pleasure minute okay
what I'm in very little pleasure carry
pleasure
come on in I I watched the whole world
in every genre and there's not a lot of
people that understand how to like cut
through culture you figured it out I'm
impressed
I'm impressed and and what's scary is
that's what I want to talk about tonight
with scary is which is starting the key
is always to have the street [ __ ] here
that's the leverage always in business
even more than a music all people care
about something they don't think it's
funny
don't like your hair they want your
attention they want the people that
[ __ ] with you to want to [ __ ] with them
you can do stuff with them that's it and
the second you don't have that person's
attention they're thrilled and thrilled
that you lost that leverage they're
happy like [ __ ] you another thing that
you want to think about filled out all
your platforms never be at the mercy of
something it's been programmed [ __ ] up
or starts fading you want to make sure
you have other places so when you hear
new [ __ ] all of this new snapchat what a
lot of people do when they're dominating
something like Instagram or the old
Twitter like now that's not good because
they made their bed on Instagram make
sure your [ __ ] date on everything
taste everything try everything you know
kids talking about house party good sign
up try it your kids talking about
musically good try it and it doesn't
matter if it goes away mine came and
went I made money while I'm around
[Music]
yeah people come people go I just sit
back and can let go I bet two windows or
dial the one who conceals it pulled it
back in that day loved people with this
power like his hot people like now
hip-hop kids are going 100 million years
because they're getting out there trying
to play at the highest level just like
athletes you go back to 63 70 vacillates
or say a job in the offseason right like
like the biggest quarterbacks in the 50
60 70 s they hope to coach when they
were done now these quarterbacks they
want to own the team you know hip-hop
kids coming up 20 years ago they're like
oh maybe I'll get like a good deal now
they want to own the label they want I
want a fashion brand new car deals
startup companies like everybody's in
for whatever that's huge it's
game-changing I'm just trying to get
youngsters to realize like don't worry
about the president
don't worry about like anything just do
your thing like state laser focused like
shits going to happen around you
regardless no matter how popular you are
you're not changing to the president is
no matter how popular we are not going
to change
whoever wants to be a racist or sexist
or just do you people spend too much
energy worrying about what they can't
control only way guy like you gets the
next step there's only two ways one also
talented you got the [ __ ] bucket you're
good enough that's it I got the truth
like it just like it's sports you can be
the biggest [ __ ] go in if you have
so much talent you're eventually going
to get to the league but how you gay
that's a whole different story
how do you make it to that second
contract that real money you're still
better off try it and losing then not
find it all flying [ __ ] pushing those
boundaries people don't get it if you
lose overtime people forget if you hit
your pioneers
people don't understand how America
works you're better off going 1 4 5 then
going over Oh
[Music]
yeah people come people go I just sit
back and let go I better do it all or
die all no one love you thank you so
much more people like the river really
they just don't be blended in I keep
just wrapping up another meeting there's
dead lice until I die that's really what
it is though guys like shaking hands
making opportunities happen you know we
go through patterns right like if you
look back at these episodes you know
obviously I'm scratching itches right
now around the hip-hop community the
culture the emerging hip-hop artists and
the trendsetters I do believe with the
emergence of social I think was a very
interesting spot right now where I think
the maturity of the young music future
players is different smarter and at
least not smarter just relevant for
where I see a 2019 2020 to world and so
I'm spending time learning I'm spending
time bringing value value exchange for
ever and so late nights worth it see you
tomorrow
yeah it's been Angie
now we're not Jackie Jackie said its
industry is doggy doggy y'all sleeping
on these making these rappers around me
that I've been eating cuz I got my city
y'all me come up and they got my back
step it up in the kidney when the worst
feeling of Oban ago when I'm certain
kill it it's the realism Chapel Hill in
the minute window